Hungary just had a celebration of its
nation's birth
in the form of Saint Stephen Day Saint
Stephen was the first king of Hungary
this was around the year 1000 and the
the government is actually Justified on
the crown of Saint Stephen so how did
they celebrate they had big festivals
all day long I was just in Budapest it's
a beautiful place and then at the end
they had these drones fly up into the
sky and create an image of the Hungarian
coat of arms then the crown of Saint
Stephen and then this is what was
controversial and crucial pun very much
intended the drones dissolved and formed
into a cross
the Cross of Christ in lights in the sky
to celebrate
the nation's identity
which is part and parcel of the
excellent prime minister over there
prime minister Orban
uh saying that Hungary is not a liberal
democracy it's an illiberal democracy
and what he means by illiberal democracy
he says is Christian democracy
we're a Christian Nation a Christian
democracy
what's so amazing you're going to hear
some Libs Screech about fascism well
it's fascist
everything I don't like is fascist
not only is this not fascist obviously
not only does this have nothing to do
with fascism
not only not only is Victor or Bond
popularly democratically elected so they
say he's a tyrant or a dictatory stolen
elections complete BS not only is
Christianity not synonymous with fascism
the fascists were actually rather
opposed to Christianity but
this is the sort of thing that we did in
our own country not so long ago
there's a picture from 1956 Rod Drayer
just pointed this out on Twitter
picture from 1956 Easter Sunday New York
City the three big buildings big
skyscrapers
all have their Windows the lights turned
on
to be crosses for Easter Sunday
all three like the three crosses on
Mount Calvary
this was New York City 1956 and in 1956
in Hungary the Communists had taken over
and and Christianity was quashed
Christianity was suppressed by that
officially atheistic regime
and Rod made the point he said
what was Unthinkable in Hungary in 1956
is happening today
and what was commonplace in America in
1956 is Unthinkable today
what a switch that is I was thinking
about this the other day because Xi
Jinping the
supposedly communist dictator of
communist China came out and he said
that he was not going to give stimulus
checks to his people because he didn't
want to get hooked on welfareism
in America we never we don't go more
than five minutes without sending people
stimulus checks in manipulating our
currency
and getting people hooked on all manner
of welfarism I mean what a bizarre time
it is when the supposedly communist
dictator of China is more capitalistic
than the United States what a strange
time it is when Hungary under communist
depression officially atheist for 45
years
is more overtly Christian than the
United States which was founded to be a
model of Christian charity a city on a
hill founded by people who call
themselves pilgrims to be a Christian
Nation what the hell happened right now
text Knowles to 200 300. for most
homeowners window replacement is not
something they've done before and for
many it isn't something that they want
to do but rather something they have to
do if you've put off replacing the
windows in your home because they're too
expensive I've got great news you can
now get a free in-home window
consultation and a free price quote from
Renewal by Anderson a company that I've
known about for a long time because my
cousin works for that company and I
forgot about that until the other day
Renewal by Anderson signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible through the
perfect combination of the best people
in the industry a superior process and
an exclusive product I'm a big fan we're
talking about stuff with your home
get the best get the best Renewal by
Anderson will hook you up it's offering
a free in-home or virtual consultation
on top quality affordable windows or
patio doors for zero dollars down zero
payments and zero interest for a year
text nulls to 200 300 for your free
consultation to save 375 bucks off every
window and 750 bucks off every door
these savings will not last long check
it out by texting nulls to 200 300 that
is nulls to 200 300 texting privacy
policy and terms and conditions posted
to textplan.us texting enrolls for
recurring automated text marketing
messages messenger database May apply
reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details before we move on from Hungary I
really like I was very impressed by
Hungary
the final objection that people are
going to make to a big cross in the
skies they're going to say well what if
you don't believe in Christianity
what if you don't believe in the rainbow
flag
I don't believe in the rainbow flag I
believe in the rainbow which is a sign
of God's promise never to destroy the
world again in a flood
I believe but the rainbow flag is
something else I don't believe in it I
don't think it's true as a matter of
human nature I don't think it's good as
a matter of virtue and I think that
Pride which it represents is the queen
of all Vice so I I'm quite opposed to
the rainbow flag
Barack Obama lit the White House up in a
rainbow flag Joe Biden just put not only
the rainbow flag but the kind of
terrorist rainbow flag you know the
really threatening one with the BLM and
all that kind of stuff put that right in
the center of the White House Portico
flanked by American flags an obvious
violation of flag code
to say this is our sacred symbol
all cultures are gonna have sacred
symbols
in Hungary what they say is
I heard this from the mouth of the
government ministers
they say look we don't we don't really
care what you personally believe and
they prove it too the Jewish quarter for
instance in Budapest is probably the
nicest Jewish quarter anywhere in the
world including Israel
beautiful vibrant really nice fun bars
second largest synagogue in the world so
they obviously are quite tolerant of
people who have other religious views
but they say but as a political matter
we're a Christian country the country's
justified by the crown of Saint Stephen
and so that's as a political matter that
that's what we're going to order our
country around the cross stands still As
the World Turns it's the axle on which
the World Turns okay and that's going to
be our national identity our national
identity right now is a bunch of fruity
rainbow flags and people doing all sorts
of decadent vicious things
it's not good but you're going to have a
symbol either way what's it going to be
what are we going to light up in the sky
to what will we pay homage and declare
our loyalty and obeisance
speaking of our Brave New World
Cuba
has just taken a major step toward a
cashless economy
Cuba which makes sense it's a tiny
little communist island nation so
they've got a lot of control over the
economy there the Cuban government just
said that entrepreneurs can no longer
take out more than 5 000 pesos in cash
that's 20 bucks
businesses can no longer take out more
than 20 bucks a day in cash
which is going to force the businesses
to do their transactions electronically
which is going to give the government a
greater ability to spy on the citizens
and figure out what kinds of things
they're purchasing controlled uh black
markets obviously but also to control
what goods are being legally purchased
if they don't like the Cubans are buying
too many beans they'll shut down that if
they don't like that the Cubans are
buying too many cigars they want to ship
the cigars off to more lucrative markets
like in China they're going to shut that
down too
and this sort of thing is coming to the
United States
there's a push for a digital currency
here you saw this during covet this was
one of the uh convenient consequences of
covid lockdowns for the liberal
establishment is that there was a coin
shortage you remember so sorry we just
can't take cash I guess you're gonna
have to pay online and then we're going
to have to see your bank statements and
then we're going to have to shut down
your money political distance have had
their Banks shut down you saw this with
Nigel farage in the UK it's not just in
the U.S either in the UK Nigel farage
major opposition leader over there was
debanked because they don't like what he
does they don't like his political
activities after all that's the man
behind the brexit
that's that's going to happen here so
what are we going to do about it we
should resist it
we should definitely resist it but
it's most likely going to happen
our our individual use of cash is not
going to stop this our cultural coming
together through Civic associations to
say we're going to use cash it's not
going to stop it
we need a political solution
this is where the politics is Downstream
of culture thing Falls flat
this is where the libertarian dream that
we can all just act individually and
that will reshape the political order
comes up a little bit short
this is happening this will happen short
of political action to stop it
we're going to have the cashless Society
even with political action we might have
it but that's the only shot we have of
stopping it
now this will the political action will
be spurred in part by individuals
gathering together in various cultural
ways the the Biden Administration
couldn't push the vaccine mandate until
enough Americans had voluntarily taken
the vaccine
that it had a a significant base of
political support that the remaining
people wouldn't be able to cause too
much trouble
that's true it's a complex interplay of
features but we need a political
solution and it's a nice sign in the GOP
that the top candidates all recognize
that fact and to the candidates who
might be more inclined to get rid of the
government or not use the hand of the
state or whatever they're all polling in
the single digits right now boy what a
great clip that was huh now make sure
you get all the clips and the episodes
and the long interviews and the games
by subscribing to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time